this movie vacation and everyone knows
the destination in the vacation movies
is wally world okay and
they're clapping for a fictional theme
park yeah they are like we love wally
world
we can't wait to go there in our minds
but this raises the question uh are you
an amusement park person do you like
amusement parks in real life i do i
really i do i used to go to magic
mountain all the time with my mom and
and we've taken my daughter to
disneyland a couple of times does she
like disney i mean is she old enough to
enjoy it um
i will preface it by saying she said to
me the other day mom you know i think
i'm old enough to really appreciate
disneyland
so um
the first time we went she was like
super cool like
kid too we were like she's gonna be fine
so the first ride we put her on was
peter pan which um immediately goes into
pitch
blackness
um and all of a sudden you just heard
blood curdling screaming from my child
that went on flipped out she flipped the
out and i mean
we were laughing so hard
wait that's how you reacted
we're wonderful parents
your two-year-old is screaming for her
life i need out stop i said josh i've
been dead we're like
[Applause]
millions of people have come here since
like 1950 something you know yeah that's
calm's a two-year-old down so people
been coming here since truman was
president
now settle down
the way we thought that we were gonna
cure it of her was by taking on her more
of those kinds of rides that day what
and it just didn't work out of course it
didn't i could have told you that pretty
much traumatized but now what four and a
half what did you take her to that was
more traumatic than alice in wonderland
which like it's traumatic because it
goes into the dark and we'd be like no
baby baby that we can see the light we
can see light we're coming out and it's
getting the light and she could just
and then like the doors
go in and like it's dark again and then
there's like a
cat and
things and like people smoking stuff and
acid and are you sure you were addicted
you're sure you were at disneyland
i think you were at scores
this is a strip club i believe uh
so is she okay now do you ever fib to
her do you ever lie to your daughter i'm
curious like every day
if i was pinocchio your eyes would be
poked out right now
that's how much i actually have lied to
her today you know it's really
interesting because people i know it's
horrible no it's you know
like you're in a bind man and they're
asking you these crazy or they're doing
something they shouldn't be doing and
you're like you keep doing that the cops
are going to come
you say the cops are going to come
that's fantastic what you're doing is
illegal right and um i'm not going to
save your ass right
okay at least
that's so you invoke the police but you
don't go beyond that right well like and
what are you implying well sometimes
parents say things like oh you know
there's a this fairy or that pharaoh oh
yeah no i do that too what do you do
santa claus fairy gloss is a good guy
what do you say santa's gonna do santa's
watching you
so
you better
cut santa's got santa's got a taser
he don't like this kind of crap kid
he gets real mad when he's been drinking
and he's been drinking all year
yeah fairies easter bunnies whoever is
like relevant at the time right you know
to take away her joy like your joy will
be taken away if you don't stop
you're a terrific person no no it is
everyone knows what their kid can handle
i believe no i would i mean yes so it's
that's all true okay i just want to get
you off the hook